like prince harry and meghan markle for
instance right
this uh according to a a gofundme
there is a gofundme set up to help
harry and megan pay off their 14 million
dollar mortgage in montecito california
that's the that's the bad news for our
culture the good news is
the gofundme has folded in less than a
week i guess this is a harry and megan
super fan
i didn't know those existed but there is
one out there at least
the the 14 million dollar gofundme
raised a total of uh
110 dollars which is
about 110 dollars too much in my mind
but then it folded up this actually ties
in with this
racialist ideology that you hear from
people like don lemon and
really you hear it from everybody
critical race theory in the classroom
and the corporate boardrooms and
everywhere else
the racialist ideology has so taken hold
in this country
that even meghan markle can claim to be
a victim
even a hot famous
rich princess
can claim to be a victim if she is even
one-quarter black my sicilian mother was
much darker than meghan markle doesn't
matter according to the
racialist ideology du jour meghan markle
can claim
to be a victim and being a victim
carries social currency it doesn't carry
real currency on gofundme apparently but
a lot of other places
it does president trump was asked
uh he was speaking to maria bartoromo
and
he was asked about his views on meghan
markle and the mexic
and her prospects because megan is it
has been
said and reported by sources close to
her that megan is looking to run for
president
in 2024 president trump gives his hot
take
what was your take on meghan markle uh
now saying she
meeting with democrat operatives she may
want to run for president
well i hope that happens because uh if
that happened then i'd be
i think i'd have an even stronger
feeling toward running
i'm not a fan of hers i think that what
she
talks about the royal family and the
queen i happen to think i know the queen
as you know i've met with the queen and
i think the queen is a tremendous person
and i'm not a fan of megan
i'm not a fan of megan i also love trump
they're like you know my friend the
queen
yeah my friend the queen she's really
great i love her
but yes if if megan were to run that
would be
all the more reason for president trump
to jump in as well it hasn't been
working this
this kind of grievance politics has not
been working
for harry and megan why not
there are plenty of other rich
successful famous people
who play into this race hustling sort of
fashionable ideology
and it does sometimes work for them why
not
harry and megan it might just be a
bridge too far
to have literal royalty
claiming grievance it might
it might just be a bridge too far if you
enjoyed that video be sure to hit the
subscribe button so
everyone waiting through the wasteland
of youtube knows that we've got
the absolute top content out there
[Music]
you